Red Alert threes cooperative campaign
invested sequel to the 99 realtime
strategy game if you have even the
remotest interest in strategy games you
need to know two things about sid
meier's civilization 5 it's fun and it's
going to keep you up really late
strategy games surround us for more than
30 years they put us in the commander's
chair at the head of interstellar
corporations and at the helm of rebel
forces combating extraterrestrial
threats they made their way from PCs to
consoles the handheld's and mobile
devices they've become pervasive and if
you look close enough a vast number of
strategy titles can be traced back to
Firaxis games and the people who worked
at that storage studio in terms of its
impact and its influence on the rest of
the gaming industry I think from a
strategy perspective that's just
unspoken 4x led to just about everything
he speaks the truth excellency I don't
want to say it's got a direct connection
with realtime strategy but even with
realtime strategy a lot of the
foundations that come from that original
civil civilization game you can see
speckled everywhere we definitely feel
like the civilization that that we got
this ball rolling in you know that we're
who everyone is looking to I see
civilization is kind of like a gateway
point for a lot of people there are a
lot of strategy games out there that are
kind of I think hard to approach for me
civilization straddles a lot of
different lines and interesting ways and
it kind of has since it first came out
it's a strategy game with a lot of depth
but it is relatively simple to approach
and as Sid likes to say it's just a lot
of simple systems interacting in complex
ways but the basic rules are pretty
straightforward
there's ideas to be found everywhere a
lot of video game designers just borrow
ideas they take ideas they think you
know what situation that idea would work
really well in and they take that and
they put it somewhere else they try
something different with it they stretch
it out they tweak it and they say that's
a really excellent mechanic and it which
really well here and I think you got a
lot of that across the strategy genre
the one thing that's that's great about
for access is we have had sort of a
continuity of Sid Meier's influence on
the way things this games get built
around here and Sid is sort of a guiding
influence for all the designers around
here civ kind of made the world safe for
strategy you know in the end of computer
games there's a nickname for Firaxis the
house that Sid built despite his name
being attached to every civilization
game since the franchise's inception
Meyer was only ever lead designer on the
first game instead offering advice and
guidance on the following titles but he
stayed busy working on numerous new
games and passion projects all the while
steering the Firaxis ship so to speak it
was kind of daunting at first you you're
kind of not sure you know it's gonna be
this real strong personality and it's
gonna like dominate meetings and people
are going to be you know worried about
speaking up and stuff and and Sid is
totally opposite of that basically if
you play civilization you are an
egomaniac I mean it it says right on the
box you know build a civilization to
stand the test of time and you're
they're like oh yeah I can do that I can
do that never so you are an egomaniac
okay he's the kind of person who
encourages creativity and lets you get
your ideas how and occasionally he'll
you know steer you back in the right
direction but it's always a you know
kind of a soft redirect rather than a
hard and firm push you know or shutting
anything off the way that they go about
making games in the way that Sid goes
about making games in particular in the
past it what makes the genre so amazing
because he never stops iterating he
never stops trying things out he never
stops trying to make things better
which is kind of spread out to every
other designer here because I matter if
it's Jake or add or any other of the
design teams they all take that
philosophy and drive it forward we don't
just start at the beginning approaching
to say this is the game we're making
these are the signs were doing and then
that's it unfortunately for us Sid isn't
always one for attention and at the time
of this video shoot he wasn't available
for interviews but here's the thing
about Sid Meier even when he's not
putting himself in the limelight there
are always five people ready to do so
for him he's mentored dozens of game
creators he's taught some of the
brightest minds in the strategy space we
do have some great designers at practice
takes the load off me and I get to play
some great games across the hall from
the civilization team is Jake Salomon
he's been called one of Sid Meier's
protégées he led the 10-year effort to
revive XCOM a series that began in 1994
under Mike repose but later switch hands
before Solomon brought it to Firaxis
just last year gamespot spoke
extensively to Solomon about XCOM 2 and
how he not only plan to keep evolving
the series but also keep Firaxis at the
forefront of the strategy genre and as
for civilization there's this running
tradition to have a new lead designer
take over each title under SIDS guidance
for civilization 6 that Padawan is at
beach I was not in computer games at all
I actually spent the first ten years of
my career in scientific satellite
programming so I worked at the Goddard
Space Flight Center and my first year
and a half there I was actually working
on the Hubble Space Telescope doing
satellite ground control systems like
even at my job at NASA I had a group of
fellow game enthusiasts and at lunchtime
I was lucky enough I had an office that
had an actual board game size table in
the office and we would just we'd use
that table and we'd play long historical
others game called history of the world
and we used to play that over and over
and over again through some of the board
game design work I did I started to meet
people who were in the hunt valley
computer game industry and just put two
and two together that hey you know why
don't you actually take your hobby and
you know make it your full-time job for
excess and Sid Meier didn't just
influence and inspire generations of new
developers they also directly train them
kind
landed a really lucky internship here at
Firaxis and as I was walking in the door
the first day I was thinking this is the
company that made Alpha Centauri this is
a company that made all the civ games
and from there on like kind of Ed Beach
took me under his wing and I learned a
lot from him and continue to do so all
throughout civilization 6 as well the
studio is a creative boot camp for some
of today's most renowned designers
Maryland's hunt valley is a mecca for
accomplished and aspiring strategy
developers alike they're working on
everything from turn-based combat titles
to economic strategy games in outer
space and if you trace their roots back
far enough many of them cut their teeth
on civilization Bruce shell eco design
the first sieve with Sid Meier and later
went on to start the age of empires
realtime strategy franchise brian
reynolds the lead designer of
civilization to would go on to create
rise of nations one of the most lauded
realtime strategy games ever made Soren
Johnson who led design on civilization
for release offworld trading company
earlier this year to critical acclaim
then there's Jon Schaffer he drew the
attention of firaxis with his
civilization 3 mods and later became
lead designer of civ 5 at just 27 years
old he worked on star docs elemental
series before breaking off to form his
own independent studio focused on
turn-based strategy titles I do think
it's just a great environment for people
to try out you know being a designer
with some of the other you know people
who have a lot of experience in the area
and you know get the kind of tutelage
and mentorship that really is going to
let them blossom in a lot of ways I
think that's what's great we've always
had this long train of designers coming
in doesn't matter whether it was you
know sworn johnson or john schaefer at
beach etc that have put themselves into
these games and they all have amazing
ideas and I have a feeling there's going
to be a long line of designers have to
come that don't know it yet that are
going to have the next great idea for
what we can take and put into
civilization I think like the sort of
Firaxis alumni and particularly going
back even further back the sort of
Microprose influence on the game video
game industry and on strategy games in
particular is really cool and it's sort
of like the roots kind of have spread
really really far and I think it's
interesting to see other things pop up
that are kind of interesting variations
on kind of what civilization and what
Sid Meier's started and we're trying to
create fun you know
and if we are not having fun a lot of
times you know it's not going to show
through if we are having fun hopefully
that'll encourage funding the player all
of this I don't think could have been
possible without that foundation thats
it originally did and I love that people
are able to take that and turn it into
this amazing series of everything that
we have now doesn't matter what forex
game is out there a lot of them have
roots in that first civilization game
and that's fantastic
you